so let's go all the way back to the
beginning of understanding what a
parameter is and what relevance it has
it's two parabolas ok so where do we
begin we began with this idea of the
locus of a parabola being to do with a
point and a line simple simple idea
right so for example with your classic
parabola we'd say s which is the focus
we put it at 0 comma a right and again
for the classic parabola where would you
put the directrix why so once you've got
this and you push it into once you push
it into the distance then perpendicular
distance formula and the to point
distance formula okay
out pops this guy a 1 where a is that
focal length there right the distance
the shortest distance between the
parabola at any given point and both of
these okay
and this has happens at the vertex right
at the origin so picture is worth a
thousand words right so let's just do a
quick stitch here okay so we had our
focus we had directory this is great
right but we decided to move past this
we wanted to understand these not just
in cartesian terms but in terms of a
parameter
what's a parameter again you can give me
a like one sentence definition of okay
let's start off it's not it's oh well
I've ended it sort of is embedded in the
parameter is this extra variable a third
variable right because I've already got
two already got two okay and the third
variable which we tend to use the letter
T about four inches
that T is what's really driving the X
and the wine right you remember the
analogy I gave you was
I'll call a shop at the beach and it's
selling sunscreen minutes selling ice
creams and those two quantities seem to
be linked as one Rises so does the other
right
but really they're not so much linked to
each other as they are linked to this
third variable language it in my tip was
temperature as the temperature rises
people don't buy more sunscreen they're
also going to bible ice cream but the
fact that they do both of those is more
of a coincidence it's about the third
thing okay so therefore we introduced
these guys we introduced these
parametric equations right linking each
of the two variables are used to talking
to to the third variable right for our
classic parabola what are our
definitions for x and y so a
which therefore implies all of those
best units all those points on the
parabola if you pick a point like P its
coordinates will be in this form in this
form right so T is like any general
parameter you like you can say that to
be any width what if I wanted to pick a
particular point I might make them
primary equal to lowercase P for that
point capital case okay capital case
uppercase P all right now we've went
there you saw that I can eliminate the
parameter by putting these two together
by substitution and I'll come back to my
original Cartesian equation right we saw
all of that the algebra was nice but
what was the point what is T what does
it represent it's not temperature what
does actually refer to in this situation
this situation yes they don't remember
it was an actual value
Oh like on the unit circle you remember
the other okay good so just in case
you're not there right the example I
gave you that you already know is the
unit circle right and on the unit circle
we're already used to using a parameter
and refers to the angle formed at the
origin between the positive x-axis and
whatever radius it is that goes to your
point right so theta that parameter is
an angle
t-this parameter is not name is learn
new angle here he refers to the grade
you on whatever tangent you've got there
not mail kind of depending on what you
refer to is theta right I'm just gonna
let I mean you could you could say that
if you write say it again find all yeah
that's a little Bailey why we do it
that's sort of your consent order if you
introduce a theater in here but you
don't have to is my point so that's why
I'm not actually I'm not gonna bring
Tate into it at least not yet
okay yes yeah so what is what is T or in
this case right it's the gradient of the
tangent at that point on the parabola
right so for instance if I say where is
T equal to zero okay now just pause you
can put it in you can put in all of that
into the corners and you get a very very
easy point out but you don't need to
think about it in terms of checking the
values in there you can think about in
terms of where is the gradient of the
tangent that's what T is all right when
is that equal zero what does zero mean
is a gradient it means a horizontal line
which takes place at the vertex right
which is why when you put t equal zero
in here you get 0 0 which of course is
it that's where the great it is around
ok all right we then extended that idea
we said ok if I've got a point over here
and a point over here I'll call that Q
right for the sake of convenience I'm
going to label its coordinates as rather
than to AP AP squared 2 AQ AQ squared
right because I can use those two those
two points and I can find out for
example the equation of the line that
the interval that joins them right and
because it's the interval that joins two
points on a curve being we call it a
very good right so we said I'm gonna pee
we said the equation of the corner we
actually derive this it's been a while
so I'll be very impressed if anyone
remembers it starts with y equals okay
I'm going to start with back on to write
P plus Q pause pause pause pause what is
this half P plus Q it's the average of
the two gradients of these are terrible
sorry of the two gradients of the two
tables right that's the average X so to
get the gradient of this chord by
average the gradients of the two
tangents right and then what do I have
hang on the nth minus a P Q so that's
all right that's why we're reviewing
kids yeah okay so there's your equation
of cord but this is just dipping out